le 11 mai peut-être qu'il y aura un
début d confie son c'est plus sachez
qu'à partir du 11 mai l on sera pas donc
voilà en configuration taille touche pas
à mon poste
on va faire une émission avant voilà une
émission voilà d'humeur avec des images
oh bien sûr des rigolades des et ont
droit chaque soir on va essayer de
mettre en place trois ou quatre
chroniqueurs avec moi bien sûr à
distance 1 et on va essayer de faire ça
ça va être de 19 heures à 20 heures et à
20 heures
on vous proposera un jeu quand je vous
dis un jeu a priori on va là c est ça
peut changer à tout moment je vous le
dis vous proposera un jeu mais quand je
vous dis un jeu ça va être un gros jeu
voilà un gros jeu voilà je pense que
vous allez être très content voilà je
peux pas vous dire encore parce que
c'est pas encore fait c'est fait et je
vous dis la chaîne aussi ce matin j'ai
eu gérald brice viret jeu francs
capitaux vincent plus jeunes donc voilà
alexandre israël tous les patrons de la
chaîne e
voilà il était aussi chaud pour
continuer à logbaba et ce soir chez ba
ba puisque l'émission je vous le dis
marche très bien
voilà le il était pourri m'ont dit
pourquoi pas continuer jusqu'à fin mai
donc on continuera comme ça jusqu'à fin
mai ou bien si vraiment ça commence à
des confiné et qu'on a des garanties on
fera ce que je vous ai dis donc une
émission avec trois quatre chroniqueurs
de 19 heures à 20 heures et un très gros
jeu que vous connaissez de 20h à 21h au
bout d'un an vers essarts bien sûr vous
verrez ça voilà vers le 11 mai donc on
vous dira et vous verrez voilà ça peut
vous plaire ça peut vous plaire je vous
dirais je vous en dis pas plus mais je
pense que ça va vous plaire